welcome back ladies and gents if you own
a Honda today I'm going to show you how
to never get locked out of your car
again by programming your Honda's key
fop and remote key at home I'm going to
walk you through a generic coding
directly from Honda that works on almost
any Honda out there with the exception
of the newer models with Advanced
security features that may require our
computer programming so fear not if your
Honda is not one of the newer models
then this video is for you today I'm
also going to be showing you all the
small tips and tricks that you need to
follow in order to make this programming
fully successful I'm going to show you
right now as you can see this remote
does not
work okay first I'm going to show you
the correct positioning that you're
going to have here as you can see there
is a one right
there as you can see this is off you
have one position second position and
there is a third position which actually
turns on the car so let's go ahead and
put this on as you can see this is First
Position which lights are not
on this is the second position which is
the one that turns on the
lights okay so now let's go ahead and do
everything that we need to
do next we're going to go ahead and
enter the car and make sure that you
have all doors are closed if the doors
are not closed the programming is not
going to be
well now in order to program your key
fob we are going to work on position one
and on position two only
so position two is where you're going to
press the lock button and once you go
back you only go back to position one
you are not going to turn it off all the
way besides the noise that you're going
to hear that you always hear before
turning on the car when the lights go on
you're also going to hear like a little
beep on the background that means that
the signal is catching in in order to
perform
the programming so we need to do this
four times so let's go ahead and start
we're going straight to position
two lock go
back position two again
click go back position three two go back
position one position two and this time
we're going to hear the
locks you hear the locks now press it
again
now the key fob is
programmed and once you turn off the
car that makes it 100% so now let let's
let's go
check and it
locks
voila now that you know how to program
your Honda's key fob and remote key let
me know your cars GE maker model down in
the comments this way all just can
understand which models this program
meal works for and which requires a
different approach as always if you like
the content of this video go ahead and
smash that like button and of course
consider subscribing for more Automotive
tips tricks DIYs and n54 content once
again thank you for watching and I will
see you guys on the next